for the reaction of iron ii oxide plus
carbon monoxide goes to solid iron and
carbon dioxide the equilibrium constant
kp is equal to 0.26 at 1000 kelvin our
goal is to find the equilibrium partial
pressures of our two gases carbon
monoxide and carbon dioxide if the
initial partial pressures are 0.80
atmospheres for carbon monoxide and .40
atmospheres for carbon dioxide
we can use the reaction quotient q to
predict which direction the net reaction
will go to reach equilibrium
so let's calculate qp
and qp
is equal to first we think about our
products and we leave solids out of
equilibrium expressions and therefore we
also leave it out of our expression for
qp so we're going to leave out iron
we're going to include uh carbon dioxide
since it's a gas so we're going to write
the partial pressure of carbon dioxide
and since we have a coefficient of one
in front of carbon dioxide it's the
partial pressure raised to the first
power
divided by next we look at our reactants
and we have a solid so we're going to
leave that out so we have another gas
carbon monoxide so this would be the
partial pressure of carbon monoxide
raised to the first power since there is
also a coefficient of one next we plug
in our partial pressures at this moment
in time the partial pressure of carbon
dioxide is .40
and the partial pressure of carbon
monoxide is 0.80
atmospheres so we plug those into our
expression for qp and 0.40 divided by
0.80 is equal to
0.50 so qp
at this moment in time is equal to 0.50
since qp is not equal to kp at this
moment in time the reaction is not at
equilibrium so qp is equal to 0.50 and
kp is equal to
0.26 so qp
is greater than kp and when qp is
greater than kp there are too many
products and not enough reactants
therefore the net reaction is going to
move to the left
next let's fill out our ice table for
this reaction i stands for the initial
partial pressure in atmospheres and so
the initial partial pressure of carbon
monoxide was 0.80 atmospheres and the
initial partial pressure of carbon
dioxide is 0.40 atmospheres c stands for
change and e stands for the equilibrium
partial pressure
calculating qp allowed us to realize
that the net reaction moves to the left
and if the net reaction moves to the
left we're going to lose some carbon
dioxide and we're going to gain some
carbon monoxide
so first let's think about carbon
dioxide we're going to lose some of it
but we don't know how much and therefore
that's going to be represented by x so
we're going to write minus x here for
carbon dioxide and since the coefficient
is a one in front of carbon dioxide and
it's also a one in front of carbon
monoxide if we lose x for carbon dioxide
we're going to gain x for carbon
monoxide
therefore the equilibrium partial
pressure for carbon monoxide would be
0.80 plus x
and the equilibrium partial pressure for
carbon dioxide would be
0.40
minus x
our next step is to write an equilibrium
constant expression for this reaction so
kp is equal to the partial pressure of
carbon dioxide divided by the partial
pressure of carbon monoxide
so the expressions for kp and qp look
the same but the difference is for kp it
would be the equilibrium partial
pressures only whereas for qp it's the
partial pressures at any moment in time
and since for kp we're talking about the
equilibrium partial pressures we can
take those directly from our ice table
and plug them in so we can plug in the
equilibrium partial pressure of co2 and
the equilibrium partial pressure of
carbon monoxide
here we can see our two equilibrium
partial pressures plugged into our kp
expression
and also the equilibrium constant kp is
equal to 0.26 for this reaction so
that's plugged in as well
our next step is to solve for x so we
multiply both sides by 0.80 plus x and
we get this and then we do some more
algebra and we get down to 1.26 x is
equal to 0.192 so 0.192 divided by 1.26
is equal to 0.15 so x is equal to 0.15
now that we know that x is equal to 0.15
we can go back to our ice table and
solve for the equilibrium partial
pressures
so for carbon monoxide the equilibrium
partial pressure is 0.80 plus x
so that's equal to 0.80
plus 0.15
which is equal to 0.95
atmospheres so that's the equilibrium
partial pressure of carbon monoxide for
carbon dioxide the equilibrium partial
pressure is point four zero minus x
so point four zero minus point 0.15
is equal to 0.25
atmospheres so that's the equilibrium
partial pressure for carbon dioxide
finally we can use the reaction quotient
qp to make sure that these two answers
for our equilibrium partial pressures
are correct so we can write that qp is
equal to the partial pressure of co2
divided by the partial pressure of co
and we can plug in those those
equilibrium partial pressures so this
would be
0.25 atmospheres was the equilibrium
partial pressure of carbon dioxide and
0.95 was the equilibrium partial
pressure of carbon monoxide and 0.25
divided by 0.95
is equal to 0.26
and since kp is also equal to
0.26 at this moment in time qp is equal
to kp and the reaction is at equilibrium
therefore we know we have the correct
equilibrium partial pressures